the jurogan experience do you know what
i said had happened at the show that i
don't know i mean this is so crazy that
this happened at a show i'm in baltimore
and
doing a great venue there like the lyric
um
and
it's it's probably 30 minutes into the
show
and
somebody says something you know it's a
theater there's out of the 2500 or some
people at the show
so but somebody says something on on
like a pause right so everybody hears it
sometimes you you navigate whether to
deal with something or not and the
bigger the rooms get you know you ignore
things this person says it like why is
bert fat or something like i'm because
he eats too much i don't [ __ ] know
right
but my response
made other people go oh this is when we
can
oh right oh i've had that happen right
so they start going they start saying
other things like podcast jokes or you
know bikes and like [ __ ] from like other
stand-up shows and i'm like okay and
then
at one point it happens you know like 10
people in a row i go do you guys do you
want to keep doing the show or do you
want me to not do this
and they're all like yeah do the show
and when i say that
another guy
jumps in from the balcony with another
comment you know like do you like old
bay on your crab or you know something
like that and i go i hope you die in a
house fire or something like aggressive
and rude
and
people laugh and i you know i just and
then i turn back and i do i just
continue with the show
but moments after that
you know when you can
you don't even hear something you feel
commotion right right it's like an
energy
so i'm i'm up there and i'm moving on
and i'm like what is that but i don't
say it i just because i just got through
dealing with
chaos
but i feel it and i look up there
and i'm just like whatever and it it
kind of dies down after a moment and i
just keep doing the show
so i get off stage
i see dave oaken
who you met my tour manager who's at the
the party
and he's like you're not gonna believe
what happened i go where he goes up in
the balcony i go yeah i sensed that
something was going on there
he goes
a guy
pulled his dick out and started pissing
on
people in the audience and i'm like what
what
he goes
he goes yeah but you know
we what we learn
is that he was aiming for somebody but
sprayed a bunch of other people
and the reason we know this is that one
of the people that got some collateral
damage
is a friend of another guy i work with
on the torque here so he's like yeah my
friend
was sitting in that section
and he goes i see this guy pull his dick
out right
and what we learn is the member the guy
that said the thing and i'm like i hope
you die in a house fire yeah
the guy behind him was like
you don't [ __ ] with tom's show
he's on my side
he's like i got tom's back
and starts to piss on him and it ends up
pissing on a bunch of people
and i go wait what did you do he goes
well we all were like get this guy the
[ __ ] out of here
so then security comes over that's the
commotion it was like people were like
trying to get security
they thought
that the guy who got pissed on was the
culprit so they go to grab him and he's
like i just got pissed on go get that
guy but it takes them a second to figure
it out and meanwhile he gets out and as
he gets up to the upper balcony exit
area he runs and he sprints outside and
they don't catch him
the pisser got free the picture got free
yeah
but he's on your side he's my team yeah
he probably just had a really p bat and
he's like you know what i got a [ __ ]
idea i'll get the heckler yeah i'll just
pee on the heckler because i have to pee
anyway
because if he's getting it everywhere
that's a heavy stream that is a heavy
stream yeah he's just spraying yeah i
was at uh one of the boston venues
and they told me after the show they're
like that was sometimes they'll tell me
you know we had three ejections or
twelve it's like you know they'll tell
me that after the show
like yeah we had to eject the guy from
the upper balcony he just uh like
squatted forward and pissed on the floor
so he didn't want to get up so they're
like
everybody's like what is this
and then everyone's like it's this guy
who's pissing in the seat jesus christ
people are [ __ ] animals they're
animals yeah oh my god one other venue
they said that a guy went he left the
aisle
and then just went to the corner like
just pissed in the corner of the theater
and they're like what are you doing
he just didn't he's like i want to go
out and miss the show
[Laughter]
so crazy
you